coverage today from east
Lansing, where the first victims
of yesterday's horrific attack
have been identified.
>> Really multiple ambulances.
>> Reporter: The shootings at
Michigan state university left
three students dead and five
others critically injured.
Brian Fraser, a sophomore,verner, were among
those killed.
Anthony Mcrae first opened fire
on the campus Monday just before
8:30 P.M.
>> Oh, my god.
>> There's still people trying
to get out.
>> Reporter: Shooting at two
locations, the first inside a
classroom.
>> While the officers were
managing that scene at the hall,
we began receiving additional
reports of another shooting at
the msu union building.
>> I'm coming down.
Seven people.
>> Reporter: One witness to the
shooting says his
fight-or-flight response kicked
in.
>> I went to the far side of the
class and ducked down, and he
came in and shot three to four
times in our classroom.
>> Police released a photo of
the shooter taken from campus
security cameras and a caller's
tip sent them to Lansing,
Michigan.
The search ended just before
midnight.
Police say Mcrae shot himself
during a confrontation and died.
He had no known motive to target
msu and no ties to the
university.
According to police, they're now
investigating a two-page note
found in Mcrae's backpack,
saying he's going to, quote,
finish off Lansing and that
there are, quote, 20 of him who
will carry out shootings
according to a source familiar
with the investigation.
Mcrae had been arrested before.
He was released from probation
in may of 2021 after pleading
guilty to a misdemeanor for
possession of a loaded firearm.
Msu students are now dealing
with what's next after spending
hours hiding from a gunman.
>> We took heavy furniture from
around the library and just
barricaded ourselves into a
study room to make sure we were
safe.
>> I was, like, shaking in the
bathroom, and it was just
terrible.
Just, like, preparing myself
for, like, the worst thing ever.
>> Reporter: Despite the tough
circumstances, there's one
greeting among all Spartans that
still unites them.
>> Go, green!
>> Reporter: You smiled
instantly.
>> As horrible and disgusting
and tragic as that was, we are
all in it together and everyone
was here for each other.
>> Reporter: That's the greeting
every freshman learns at
orientation, and today it
provided a moment of comfort for
those hurting students,
especially as they learn more
about this 43-year-old shooter.
His father spoke to CNN, telling
us his son changed about two
years ago when his mother died
following a stroke.
He said his son became isolated,
bitter, and, quote, evil angry.
Jake?
>> Adrienne Broaddus in east
Lansing, Michigan, for us.
Elissa Slotkin of Michigan joins
me from the university.
She Lansing and
the campus.
Congresswoman, I'm angry we're
having this conversation again.
I'm sure you are too.
This is the second mass shooting
at a school in your area in the
last year and a half, the first
oxford high school in 2021.
First, how is your community
doing today?
>> Yeah, well.
Look, it's the first day after a
huge trauma.
You know, for a while it was
just a very quiet and empty
place, the campus.
Kids were really holed up in
their dorm rooms, in apartments.
We were making sure kids were
together, they had someone else
to be with.
We're starting to see a few
folks come out and want to be
together.
They're planning vigils, taking
action, planning protests.
They're starting to come out,
but it is particularly because
it wasn't just a shooting, it
was also a manhunt on campus.
It was sort of a double trauma
in a way.
And everyone felt the effects.
Over 50,000 students are here,
so it's a traumatic thing that
will take a while to get over.
>> Nothing could explain this
madness, but have you learned
anything about a possible
motive?
>> Reporter: No.
I mean, I think to everyone's
best estimate at this point is
it was someone who was going
through a real mental crisis.
And, you know, by his own family
admission, he was just
struggling, and this person who
was struggling with mental
illness had access to a gun, had
regular access to a gun.
And, you know, we'll never I'm
sure know exactly why he did it,
but I think, you know, the thing
that's just hard to ignore is
how many times we've done this
over the past just even year,
year and a half.
And, you know, are we willing to
have an actual conversation
about doing something to
mitigate these kind of gun
losses.
It's been a frustrating day.
You know, I'm not someone who
usually fears -- feels-like fury
about something, but having to
talk to kids, I mean, you should
have heard the conversations,
talking to students.
They were terrified, their
parents were terrified.
It's terrorizing, and we do
something about something that's
terrorizing our population or do
nothing.
That's the choice.
>> So many shooters in the last
few years have had run-ins with
the law or family members who
said, yeah, he was really going
through a tough time.
This shooter's father says his
son had a gun several years ago.
Police took it away.
Court documents show the gunman
pleaded guilty to a firearms
charge in 2019.
And yet sources tell CNN this
same person was able to purchase
both guns in 2021.
Is that legal in Michigan?
Do we have any idea of whether
this could have been stopped in
any way, the purchasing?
>> Reporter: Yeah.
We really just don't know the
full details yet.
I don't want to speculate.
I think, you know, the fact of
the matter is we know it's a
pretty high bar to get flagged
when you're trying to purchase a
weapon.
And I don't know the
circumstances of this man, but I
know someone who's closest, you
know, family felt that they were
mentally unstable, had access to
a weapon.
I think one of the things that
at least has made me feel a bit
better is that we've had an
outpouring of Michigan ganders.
So many people here are Spartans
and graduated or used to come by
msu.
There's a feeling you can be a
gun owner, a sportsman, avrd
hunter, grow up with weapons the
way I did, and still believe in
keeping kids safe in a place of
sanctuary like a school.
So, I think what has heartened